щоб перемогти хворобу потрібно точно
встановити діагноз щоб перемогти у
двобої зі злом важливо називати речі
своїми іменами цією постановою
український парламент на законодавчому
рівні офіційно визнає що в основі
російського режиму лежить новий різновид
тоталітарного ідеології та практики
расизм У заяві Верховної Ради йдеться
про те що рашизм ґрунтується на
традиціях російського шовінізму і
імпералізму практика комуністичного
режиму СРСР та на німецького
націонал-соціалізму це дуже важливо для
розуміння природи зла з яким зіткнулася
Україна і весь цивілізований світ тому
що нинішня війна - це не просто війна
Путіна ідеологію рашизму глибоко
просякнуто все російське суспільство і
хоча рашизне слідує світогляд і естетику
гітлерівського і сталінського режимів
його коріння набагато глибші рашизм
міцно настоявся на особливостях
російської державності культури
задавлений у соціальній ненависті не
подоланих імперських амбіціях і
агресивному реваншизмі засуджуючи рашизм
ми констатуємо що розв'язана проти
України війна є його прямим наслідком і
Закликаємо світову спільноту об'єднати
зусилля для подолання загроз які раси
несе для миру і безпеки усього людства
підтримуючи цю Постанову Верховна Рада
зробить важливий крок для поширення у
світі розуміння суті й причини цієї
війни а отже і до наближення Перемоги в
цій війні Слава Україні